connaissez-vous Peter Parker qui est
Spider-Man oui, c'est lui non,
pouvez-vous s'il vous plaît expliquer ce qui se passe
après avoir arrêté ce sort, nous avons commencé à
recevoir des visiteurs de tous les univers, le
multivers est réel,
j'ai besoin que vous les capturiez avant qu'ils ne
détruisent le tissu de  réalité, je vais avoir
besoin d'aide, vous les gars, soyez prêts, attrapons des
hommes du multivers,
Spider-Man, rentrez chez vous, quel était votre
nom encore, Dr Otto Octavius,
sérieusement, quel est votre vrai nom,
vous n'êtes pas Peter Parker, je suis tellement confus
en ce moment, ce
sort qui  vous avez acheté, vous avez commencé à
attirer des visiteurs de tous les univers,
le multivers est réel,
ils meurent tous en combattant Spider-Man, il
doit y avoir un autre moyen, ils ne représentent pas
un danger pour notre univers,
c'est entièrement de ma faute, je ne peux pas sauver
tout le monde, les
araignées.  - mec, pas de retour à la maison au cinéma le
17 décembre,
que se passe-t-il, ils commencent à
s'en sortir et je ne peux pas les arrêter
quand tu penses que je suis sur le point de faire
quelque chose qui pourrait briser l'univers,
je sais que tu le diriges par nous,
nous  Je dois les renvoyer, tu ne
vas pas m'enlever ça,
tu t'envoles dans les ténèbres pour
combattre des fantômes, qu'est-ce que tu veux dire, ils
meurent tous en combattant Spider-Man, je suis désolé gamin,
ouais, moi aussi, je n'en ai pas.
être une autre façon là-bas, ce
n'est pas
Spiderman, pas de chemin à la maison le 17 décembre,
tu